صديقي والله كي لا
نخبئ الشمس بغربال الدراما السوريه تمر
بتحديات
هذه التحديات مرده لعناصر كثيره انت تعلم
يا صديقي انه في التسعينات وحتى منتصف ال
2000 كانت الدراما السوريه تتبوا مكان
حقيقه في صداره الدراما العربي
لكن بالحروب وكما يحدث في الحروب وكما
يحدث وكما يحدث دائما بالاصطفاف السياسي
كما يحدث في الحروب من تدمير للبناء
التحتيه من ظروف حرب الاخر بمعنى هناك
اصبح مشكله بغياب راس مال مغامر راس مال
ثقاف راس مال يستطيع ان يغامر واضيف له
حصار التسويق الدراما السوريه وانت لما
بتصنع منتج لا تضمن تسويقه بالضروره لن
تهتم كثيرا فيه لانه هو لم يعد منتجا
للتصدير وشروط تصدير غير مضمونه وجاءت
الدراما السوريه بهذا المكان حي الشديد
واعتقد انها الان هي في مخاض حقيقي ولابد
من حل مشكلته اذا همم
اذا فتحت السواق امام الدراما السوريه
لانه انت بتعرف يا صديقي نحن ما عندنا سوق
داخليه للدراما يعني لا نملك عدد كما مصر
الشقيقه عدد كبير من المحطات التلفزيونيه
فهذا المنتج اذا لم تفتح امامه افاق
التسويق هو لن يرى النور بالاخر انت تتحدث
عن صناعه ثم اذا لم يعاد ترتيب البناء
الخدميه والتحتيه وكل الشروط التي توفير
ارضيه حقيقيه لانتاج الدراما متفرده
ثم طبيعه المواضيع نحن رحلتنا مع الدراما
في مطلع التسعينات كنا دائما بنقول لماذا
استطاعت الدراما السوريه ان تنتزع لها
مكان مختلف حقيقه لانها تحركت في فضاءات
متنوعه بدءا من اعاده الانتاج الادب
الروائي الى الاعمال الوطنيه والنظاليه
شعبنا خلال سنواته الى اعمال الاسره
والعائله ان كانت كوميديا الى الاعمال
التي تتناول بام المؤسسات الرسميه
النظام من ناحيه سياسيه
النظر انقسام الشعب السوري حاله الفرز
الاجتماعي والسياسي والطائفي وكل هذه
الامور ضيقت هذه المساحه اللي كانت موجوده
امامكم
نحن لا ليس لدينا مساحات على مستوى
الرقابي مازلنا الى حد بعيد نتحرك بمواضيع
جريئه مشكلتنا التسويق هذا المنتج مشكلتنا
تسويقه انت لما يضرب عليك حصان ثم يا سيدي
الحروب دائما لو عدنا لتاريخ كل المجتمعات
المعاصره في سنوات الحروب اصلا يتعلم منها
المبدعون ويستطيع ان يخرجوا انتاجا جدا
وهم ليست الحروب دائما كارثه الحروب مثلا
راح يجيب لك مثال انتاج المؤسسه العامه
للسينما في سوريا قبل الحرب كان كل سنتين
فيلم واحيانا كل سنه باحسن الاحوال كم
الانتاج السينمائي ليه المؤسس العامه
للسينما خلال سنوات الحرب كان بمعدل
يتجاوز خمس افلام روائيه في العام
وعشرات الافلام القصيره يعني قصدت نفس
الشيء بالحال المسرحيه نحن نشتري اما
التليفزيون باعتباره صناعه يعني انت تحتاج
الى السوق تسوق به هذا المونتاج بغياب سوق
داخلي كانت التحديات شديده لذلك دراما
حقيقه تعيش في مخاض اما الان يتم
الاستعانه ببعض كوادرها المتميزه للعمل
خارج سوريا او انها تحصر في زاويه الدراما
الشاميه لسبب رئيسي لا غير هو ان هذا
النوع مما سمي بدرام البيئه الشاميه لا
يمكن صناعته الا في سوريا وانا حتى بعدين
لو كان ممكن يتساوى برات سوريه كمان
اقصى الدراما السوريه